Welcome back everyone
It's Charlie
Tom Hiddleston and Marvel
dropped a teaser for Loki Season 3
and revealed some of their plans for the future of God
Loki, as they're officially calling him up, Marvel
And we learned why Loki has not used his God tier power
to kill the Council of Kangs
because it normally would seem like
it's a pretty easy thing for him to do
if he can control the multiverse that way.
in a lot of it's because of how Marvel
is changing their plans for Avengers five.
Kane Dynasty in Secret Wars.
As a lot of you probably have guessed
Separately, there have been a lot of reports
about Marvel changing their plans for Jonathan Majors.
Kang Just in general, all explained
what's going on with that.
It is a really big deal
and it is pretty late in the game for Marvel.
As we get closer to Avengers five,
if you're brand new to the channel,
be sure to subscribe to get all the videos.
The next big Marvel series I'll be doing
episode videos for will be What If season two
That'll be at the end of this year.
We'll get some more trailers for that pretty soon.
that'd be very loosely related to what's happening
during Loki season
two with the multiverse
just shifting in such a huge way.
Pretty much everything is starting to lead
towards Avengers five and Avengers
six recently, because the strikes ended, all
the actors are actually allowed to talk about the show.
So Tom Hiddleston was actually allowed
to talk about the Loki Season
two ending in the future of the Loki character.
he was asked if the Loki season two ending
was his final time as the character,
and he basically called it a bookend for his time
as Loki.
Like the last 14 years
since he was cast in the first Thor movie.
But then.
Separately was very careful
to reiterate that he was not done
as the Loki character Loki would return it
all comes full circle.
it's the conclusion to season two.
It's also the conclusion to seasons one and two.
It's also the conclusion to six films and 12 episodes
and 14 years of my life.
what Deadpool would say about Loki.
I think he'd be withering, although, you know, Loki
famously has a silver tongue,
so I think he'd give as good as it gets.
written to Kevin Feige and Louis D'Esposito
we're always here.
You know, you've given us
so much I'd be unwise at this point
to be conclusive about any of it.
that's it basically saying he'll be back in
so many words being kind of secretive about it.
So Kevin Feige's Marvel snipers
don't destroy him on the spot literally.
Robert Kirkman was just dropping a whole bunch
of spoilers about what's going on with The Sentry
and Steven Yeun's character promoting the Invincible
show that he's currently working on.
but his reasoning for getting away with spoiling
what's happening
with the Thunderbolts movie in Sentry
is that he doesn't actually work for Marvel.
So he's like, What are they going to do to me?
this is a spoiler or anything
that'll get anybody in trouble.
I don't know. Maybe we'll see. Carol, work for Marvel.
They're going to do to me the answer to
that would probably be threatening to sue him.
But the Loki.
Season two showrunner
Kevin Feige also said that the season two finale
was not meant to be the same kind of cliffhanger
season one.
Not that it would be like the last time
we'd ever see the character justice.
They didn't want there to be a giant question
mark at the end, was they were kind of misleading about
because there were still a ton of questions
at the end of the Loki Season two finale,
like what's going to happen next?
they were mostly referring to the fact
that Loki wouldn't just like find another Kang behind
everything else, like they wanted him to deal with
he who remains and outsmart him, and for that to stick,
He created a new version of the multiverse fashioned
after the world tree.
He's sitting at a center in that golden throne
made from the remains of he who remains
Citadel at the end of time, and his chair
holding it all together.
So all of his friends who themselves are
variants, can survive in their own timelines.
But they didn't want to say that
he'd be stuck there on his golden throne
at the center of reality for the rest of time.
Just that they wanted him to successfully outsmart
he who remains
then the Loki season two showrunner said that
Loki Season three had not been written yet.
The operative word yet
I think it's interesting that Loki never comes up.
That never comes face to face with Spider-Man.
we are Loki at Loki
and Strange is an interesting match up, I think.
The producers said that they did plan to reunite
this version of Loki with the main version of Thor.
Eventually,
And they did confirm that they're basing this new Loki
more on God of stories, Loki
being able to jump around in his own timeline.
But obviously the MCU version being a little bit
different from the comic book version.
in basically that Loki would be back in Avengers
5 Kang Dynasty and during Secret Wars,
it's kind of the same plan that they have
for the Scarlet Witch character.
Like they're this really big final seeming moment
for the character, but there's a big question mark
about their future at Marvel.
But But really what they're doing is just giving them
like, a short break and then waiting
for, like, the next big Avengers movie
to bring them back in a much bigger way.
so really.
Loki Season three wouldn't happen
until all that Avengers stuff winds up going down
in a lot of the events of Loki Season three, which is a
spin out of how they wind up ending secret wars.
We know there's going to be some kind of soft
reboot marvel.
Kevin Feige is going to fix any continuity issues
recast whoever he wants to recast
and bring everybody into a single continuity
is the new MCU going forward.
Looks more like the true comic book 616 universe where
everybody's co-existed in the same universe
the whole time.
and here's where we get to the issue of why
Loki or the God version of Loki has not killed
the Council of Kangs yet with all of his power
a lot of it has to do with Marvel's
changing plans for Avengers five in Avengers six,
mostly the villains in those movies,
most mostly you price other reports
separately that the Disney CEO, Bob Iger,
was personally putting his thumb on the scale,
so to speak, and will make Kevin Feige recast
Jonathan Majors
regardless of what happens with his upcoming trial,
it doesn't matter whether he's found innocent or guilty
either way.
Apparently the major money people like a level above
Kevin Feige who give all the Marvel people
their marching orders are just tired of all the
headaches and the drama that come from Jonathan Majors.
But generally the belief is that Marvel has invested
way too much time in leading up to Avengers
five as Kang Dynasty for them to completely change
what Avengers five winds up being
lot of you also thought that they might just wind up
absolutely canceling Kang Dynasty and making Avengers
five just like a larger version of secret wars
That's not totally out of the cards,
but things would have to get way, way worse
behind the scenes for them to do something that major.
they just delete all their movies that are happening
next year except for Deadpool three, meaning that
Avengers five would not be able to happen until 2026
in secret wars wouldn't be able to happen until 2027.
So at least right now without things getting way
way worse at Marvel
the report is they'll just recast Jonathan Majors
and proceed with Avengers
five as a version of Kang Dynasty,
meaning the Avengers versus the Council of Kangs,
Which is the real reason why the new God
Loki hasn't killed the Council of Kangs with his power.
because they still plan on doing a larger version
of the Kang Multiverse War in Kang Dynasty,
with several versions of the character
just played by a different actor
in Universe, though, the story reason
like the logical reason why Loki didn't kill the Kang
variant is because the Council of Kangs
exists in a pocket dimension outside of time.
The same way the TV aided in Loki
could really only affect things inside those timelines.
So in order for him to use his power to kill
the Council of Kangs, he'd have to have left the chair
and entered the actual dimension
where the Council of Kangs is located.
And that would have caused the timeline
branches in the multiverse to die again.
in. They were going to do that literally right after
he sat down in the chair and takes the multiverse.
my early theory
about how they actually get him out of the chair
because he'll have to get out of the chair for Avengers
five.
is they just say the Council of Kangs
starts going around blowing up different timelines
with Avengers in them to slowly kill all the Avengers
and Loki starts feeling it through the timeline.
The branches in his chair.
there's this line in Norse
mythology about the actual world tree itself.
Basically, when the world tree shakes
it means that Ragnarok is upon them again.
So think of Avengers 5 Kang Dynasty.
This battle against the Council of Kangs is like a much
larger cosmic version of Ragnarok than actual Thor.
Ragnarok.
Loki will be sitting there in his chair and all of a
sudden he'll feel the branches of the timeline.
The world tree literally starts
shaking and dying around him.
They'll give him a version of the scene
they gave the Hulk at the beginning of Avengers
Infinity War, where Rodrigo's
to the main version of Thor, warns him about
what's happening in They assemble the New Avengers
then I do believe that they plan
on completely moving past the whole concept of Kang
at the end of Avengers 5.
Like they will kill the Council of Kangs.
Whoever winds up being the villain of Avengers six,
there were reports they might just pivot to Dr.
Doom.
It could totally wind up being a different character,
like a more comic book accurate version of the Beyond,
because they are basing secret wars
on both of the comic book versions of Civil Wars.
the classic version from the 1980s
and the more modern version. but.
Pending the resolution of secret wars, the creation
of a new, more comic book accurate multiverse
with a bunch more X-Men, they just use Loki Season
three to sort of explain how Loki helps
reform this new version of the multiverse
with the soft reboot that Marvel is doing.
at the end of the more recent secret wars,
they let Reed Richards and Franklin Richards
be the ones to do that.
They helped recreate the multiverse.
They can just say that
God Loki is the person to do that in the MCU.
That's basically what he's kind of doing
during Loki Season two.
He's basically reforming the multiverse.
you can just have him being a bigger part
of how they do that.
During Avengers 6 Secret Wars.
Let me know in the comments.
If Marvel does recast Jonathan Majors,
how do you want them to end Avengers 5 Kang Dynasty
and who do you want the villain of Avengers
six Secret Wars to be?
Dr. Doom would be cool if they can actually develop
the character well enough before that movie happens,
But if they are having to delay
all their movies so much, then we'll all be old men
and old women before secret wars winds up happening
anyway.
theoretically, they do have a lot of time
to develop the Doctor Doom character,
Apparently they just talked to Mads Mikkelsen
about being Dr.
Doom in the MCU.
Would you actually be a pretty solid choice
I'll do more videos about all those different things
when we get more information.
It's still pretty early days right
now, like the strike just ended, so they just ramped up
production on all these different movies
and all of these different shows.
it's kind of like Kevin Feige
just like ran into all their production studios
and started flipping the lights on back again
and sort of rousting everybody, get back to work,
start making our stuff again.
like I said, the what if season two episodes
will be coming at the end of the year?
It will be like an advent calendar
with like a new episode every single day.
it'll be interesting
to try and get all those videos out in a timely manner.
click here for the brand new trailer video
for that and click here
for my Loki Season 2 Episode 6 Finale Video.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one!